now in the coming hours queen elizabeth
coffin will begin the first stage of its
journey towards her funeral in london on
the 19th of september a hearse will
carry the coffin on a six-hour drive to
the palace of holyrood house in the
scottish capital edinburgh it will rest
there overnight before a church service
on sunday people have already laid
flowers and mementos outside the palace
let's now speak to rob matheson who's at
balmoral in scotland so the first stage
rob of the queen's final journey will
begin in about two hours or so talk to
us about the rules the funeral cortege
is going to be taking it's going to be a
slow journey deliberately designed that
way to allow people to pay their
respects
exactly that's absolutely key to to
something like this people want to be
able to to give their say their final
farewell to the woman who has ruled
their country uh for the longest period
of any monarch in
in the uk it is going to be queen
elizabeth's final journey from bel model
castle here in in scotland the hearse
that's carrying her coffin will make its
way down the driveway here it's going to
turn right at the top of the driveway
and its first stop is going to be the
local village of baloter and that is a
village that has uh very close
connections with the royal family the
villagers there for years have been used
to seeing the the royal family in very
informal circumstances driving their
cars
around the streets or as the queen used
to do in her younger years going
shopping in the local stores
the cottage after uh leaving ballater is
going to follow a route
along a road called the a93 it's the
most direct route that will take it to
the coastal city of aberdeen
it's going to do a small tour of
aberdeen to allow people there to make
pay their respects and then it will head
southwards to edinburgh and the palace
of hollywood as you just mentioned we
are expecting uh many people to be
lining this route the weather is very
very good today and also the a93 route
passes through several smaller towns in
villages we're expecting a great many
people to be turning out to say their
final farewells as well the police have
been out croning off the road to make
sure that there are no obstructions
and that the cortege will have a clear
run and that everybody will have a very
clear view of the cortege as it moves at
a very slow pace as you mentioned uh
towards to make that that that journey
but what is important is the fact that
this particular day is a chance for the
local people here who have been working
in and around the state for so many
years to say their farewell to the woman
who has run the country for so long but
whom many of them regard simply as a
neighbor i was going to ask you about
that bob it's a poignant moment for for
the people who live there for the people
of scotland isn't it
it definitely is i mean i think
particularly for the people who have uh
been
around the royal family and have been
used to the royal family being here uh
for so many years
the family has regarded uh
balmoral as very much a family home and
differently to the way that they regard
buckingham house buckingham palace for
example which has often been described
by them as essentially a home office
it's somewhere they live but it's also
somewhere that they they work from and
of course the wall family has many
different properties uh around the
country but this was always a favorite
they were always in very um proud of
their scottish connections the fact that
they lived they had the house here in
scotland partly because
of the geographical location of it and
also the trees the foliage that that hid
the house and the mountains around it
that kept it so private and allow them
to be so uh relaxed and comfortable and
to be in as one point they used to
describe it as simply being another
family and interestingly because they
were able to be so relaxed they were
therefore much more open to talking to
uh the the local people and the local
people over the years have come to
protect that privacy and it means a
great deal to the local community here
that the royal family
still will retain this house
thank you for that rob matheson live
outside balmoral castle in scotland
where the first stage of queen elizabeth
final journey will begin this sunday as
a coffin is moved from balmoral to
edinburgh in scotland we'll follow that
throughout the day here with you of
course rob and the rest of our teams
there on the ground thank you for the
moment